ion we are experiencing an irresistible  gravitational pole this is not a  simulation I repeat not a simulation  we have a lot of work ahead of us ion  you are a trainee on a forgotten planet  this could easily solve all of our  resource problems on p1 we need to phone  home  [Music]  a private Cruiser how did that get here  who are you little Explorer  have you seen Arnie my mobile you hit  she's our only hope she's fierce and  brave but also prone to trouble  anything regular about this planet  be very careful ion if you failed  we are both finished awakened something  and whatever it is it's trying to kill  us  I own account read your signal I please  report out